for three years i recorded two videos a
week and i put them in a a facebook
group uh because i didn't understand how
youtube worked and uh over that time
period i got better at communicating and
things like that um but there was a
specific video that was uh among the
most watched and most shared videos um
that i ever made and i thought i would
share it here with you guys mozi nation
uh for those of you guys who don't know
my name is oxford the own
acquisition.com you know portfolio
companies that does about 85 million a
year now in the video it's from the past
so if you hear some of the numbers that
are in there
it's what i was doing at that time um
and this specific video is incredibly
valuable to me because it was one of the
videos that really set me free in
understanding the true single most
valuable resource that we have as
entrepreneurs and how most entrepreneurs
are leaking it and once i plugged that
hole for myself is when i started seeing
explosive growth uh in my business but
also in my life overall and so i wanted
to share this video because i think it's
incredibly valuable and the the
marketplace of attention has said that
this was one of the most valuable videos
ever made and so i wanted to share with
you hope you guys enjoy
this is a little bit less common for me
i'm uh
i was i'm going to make a video or i
guess
podcast depending on how you're
consuming this on a pretty pie in the
pie in the sky topic um and i titled
this the new entrepreneurial golden
resource and how you're probably leaking
it so a lot of people don't know this
but uh i probably i would say a
mentor four or five people on the side
not in a formal business setting in
terms of like them paying me or anything
like that but just people that are have
become friends that i've taken interest
in their business and i've helped them
along and
invariably and what's interesting is
that the higher up you go the less
tactical the mentorship is and so i have
so i've had i've had the fortune of
actually connecting and befriending my
my first billionaire friend which is
cool and what's
what's happened as a result of that is
that like i i obviously obsessively look
at what people who are doing better than
me are doing and then when i'm relaying
to the people who are who i'm trying to
help there's this one resource that
people who make a ton of money manage
extremely well and people who um do not
do not and a lot of people i would say
mistakenly think that the number one
resource is time
right everyone's like time is money time
is money time is money
and i would argue that that's not
necessarily true i would argue that
attention is money that is the golden
resource so the billionaire friend that
i have he's actually been helping me on
um the new endeavor that we are
launching to our gym lords uh soon which
i think will change the industry anyways
he's been helping me with that stuff but
like here's an example
on his phone his phone does not ring
unless you are already a contact that
has been whitelisted
his phone doesn't ring it's he is
impossible to reach the more successful
the more the the larger your company
grows the more you scale the more you
need to scale the only way to scale you
is because you do have a finite amount
of attention and so what happens is you
have to decrease all of the other things
in your life that drain attention
because you can have as much time as you
want but if you're not there you're not
potent you're not able
then you can't get anything done with
that time that you're supposedly
allocating which is why a lot of people
end up in this in-between state of
always everywhere and at the same time
nowhere right and so they're they're
everywhere but they're not paying
attention to anything and that's and the
reason that it's difficult to focus is
because entrepreneurs the character
trait that made us into entrepreneurs is
that we're go getters we're we're
risk-averse we're creators we're
innovators we're builders right we have
all of those traits but the difficulty
is is that the thing that gets you from
zero to one is not the thing that gets
you from one to two right and so one of
the the reason that you have to totally
morph and why you have to be a growth
oriented individual is because you have
to change your own individual character
traits in order to progress as a
business owner and so like i said the
things that got you here are not the
things that are going to get you there
the things that got you here which is
your own internal skills are not the
things that you need to pass on to other
people so the only way that you were
able to grow your business at a certain
point is by growing other people right
and the only way you can do that is if
you have the attention and the bandwidth
in order to do so and that's why if you
look at a business owner and like the
more i obsess on looking at billionaires
and people who are doing better than we
are is i look at how quiet and how clean
they keep their space and i mean that
both both in a literal sense that like
their surroundings their office their
house their homes their cell phone their
computers right there it's it's it's
quiet right everything like it's it's
pristine
and when you talk to these people
there's a certain amount of of
tranquility that's there and
and they just they just have very low
tolerance
and it's not that they're trying to be
impatient with you or impatient with the
world it's just that they understand
that they have so like they're they're
operating at such a high level that
there's so many things that are
demanding of their time and attention
that they just like they can't and so
they have to forcibly remove themselves
from so many different situations and
i'm going to give you an example so one
of the people that i'm i'm i'm somewhat
mentoring right they had they had four
businesses and this is something that
that happens so many times it lit like
like you want you want a hundred
thousand dollar coaching this is what
happens in hundred thousand dollar
coaching sessions and i'm being honest
with you what happens is someone who's
coming in usually doing between one and
three million dollars a year um can't
get past a certain point right and the
reason they can't get past is because
they only have so much attention they've
spread between four or five different
cases that's when the gym owner has four
gyms and is making less money than they
did when they had one gym because the
amount of attention that they can
allocate to one facility has gone down
so much that with fixed costs they
basically are breaking even right and so
the same thing happens now that
entrepreneur is probably making one to
three million in gross revenue but not
taking anything home because they don't
have the attention actually put onto
things and so in order to grow you need
to do less
in order to grow you need to do less
and that comes from both delegation and
also
choosing what not to do the better you
get the better the opportunities that
you have to say no to
imagine the level of opportunities that
we have now i'm just being honest so
imagine
how many things we could do or trying jv
with or do a partnership with or
whatever because of the distribution
network that we have and the trust and
the goodwill that we have with the gym
owners um that we have in our network
right a lot i get i you know how many
people
cold message me like i have an
opportunity for you i'm like really you
have an opportunity for me and so the
better you get the better your
opportunities you have to say no to
which is why becoming a higher and
higher and higher level entrepreneur is
more and more difficult because it
requires discipline
it's not about doing more it's about
doing less because we innately want to
do more so doing more of your own
internal characteristic if that was what
it took to get to be more successful
then everyone would be more successful
because it would be something that does
not take effort because that is
something that we already do it's like
man i outwork anyone i've got all this
work with it cool that gets you from
zero to one
it's not gonna get you any further than
that so stop identifying with that it
was something that i used to identify
with i was like i'll i'll outwork anyone
or whatever like that was something that
i used to think about and it was a
character trait it was an identity thing
and the more you grow the more you
realize that your identity needs to be
fluid because what it needs to be is
exactly what it needs to be at that
given time of development because the
character traits that i'm going to have
to emphasize in a year are going to be
different than the ones that i have to
emphasize now the skills that you need
to learn like delegation
leadership those are things that are not
the things that take you in the
beginning you have to be independent you
have to be
a hustling you have to be grinding you
have to be willing to put in the work
because no one else will do it for you
especially if you have no capital to
start which most people who are on here
are in that situation to reel this back
in
the number one thing that you have to be
paying attention to
is where you are paying your attention
right like you spend attention that's
why they call it paying attention it's
because it is a resource and most people
don't pay attention to that right and so
one of the things that a lot of people
don't know about me this one's going to
go along um
some of the things that a lot of people
don't know about me is that i for
nine months
paid a coach to teach me one thing which
was to manage my attention was to teach
me how to think
and so for 90 minutes every single day
all i did was talk about what i was
thinking about
think about that
every day i paid attention to where my
attention was
and when i did that all of a sudden my
business blew up
right and i realized that i had toxic
relationships i had toxic relationships
with parents i had toxic relationships
with friends or pseudo friends things
that i that were taking my attention
past things that i had on my mind that i
knew i had not handled so those are
called like open loops or open cycles
right so when you have something that
you like i haven't resolved this then
you need to handle that and you'll get
that attention back because what happens
is you have this bowl this tiny little
bowl of marbles that each of those
marbles is is a unit of attention right
if you had to measure it and so you put
little marbles of attention on your
childhood traumas you put little marbles
of attention on your marriage you put
little uh marbles of attention on your
health you put little marvel's attention
on your spirituality and then massive
marbles of attention on your business
but the thing is is that sometimes you
need to quiet and collect all of these
other little marbles so that you have
more potency more potential energy more
potential units of attention to spend on
the one thing that you're trying to grow
which in this case would be your
business and what's interesting is that
what happens is that things that were
perceived as difficult become really
easy and i don't know if you've ever had
this happen but like if you were in
college or you were in high school and
you're like man i can't solve this
problem this math problem and you were
exhausted then you go to bed and you
wake up the next morning and then all of
a sudden it seems really easy you're
like i don't know why i didn't see that
before because attention gives you the
ability to see
right like if you're if you think about
wisdom right wisdom is an ability to see
what other people cannot see
right two people are presented the same
situation the wiser person sees things
that the other person doesn't and how
can you see better you see better if you
have more ability to see which comes
from your most valuable resource
attention how much horsepower do you
have and so look at the things that you
have in your in your life right now like
if i see someone who has a messy
relationship life who's got a messy love
life who goes out every weekend and gets
trashed right like i can tell you
billionaires don't do that that like the
whole tony stark like
vision of the entrepreneur is a farce
it's not true don't believe that every
single billionaire every single
high-level entrepreneur is quiet
unbelievably quiet they keep themselves
completely isolated they have a bubble
around them of of layers of protection
they're like like for me it's it's
me and then there's layla and then we
have our co and then we have our
executive assistant team because we have
a team of eas at this point we have four
um who work the next level there's no
one who has direct
access to me including our employees no
one does
and that's because it's it would
disserve you
you guys our gym owners if everyone had
access to me the reason that i don't
respond to facebook messages is not
because i don't want to it's because i
literally can't and if i did i would be
disturbing everyone because then my
attention would be split because someone
can't generate leads in their mind or
whatever you know what i mean like
because these little things these little
things that are perceived as huge issues
to you in that moment because you have a
little bit of attention
you you have so little left that
everything seems like an explosion but
when you have lots of capacity big
problems seem small and small problems
seem big and it sounds reverse because
what you do is you start seeing that all
of these things are attention drains and
you just say i don't want to play
anymore
then you stop playing
and then all of a sudden everything gets
really simple because the only things
you have to do become really simple at
our gym lord's event one of the things
that we had to do or that i had everyone
do
was simply define the number that they
needed to have in their gym number of
efts in order to have the lifestyle that
they wanted to have really simple simple
process
most people didn't have that but it's
amazing what happens when you have
clarity because then it allows you to
put your attention in one direction
right and then it gives you a litmus
test will this help me grow this number
yes or no yes cool let's do it no ignore
it right and it takes discipline to say
ignore it
it takes discipline
that's why it's hard that's why most
entrepreneurs aren't successful that's
why most entrepreneurs don't grow is
because it's hard it's counterintuitive
it's counter your character and so you
have to learn how to not be yourself in
order to be the person that you want to
be
and that's why that's why most people
don't do it and so to go ridiculously
full circle on this
every time i meet with an entrepreneur
and i told you we i
coach is probably a loose term but i'll
meet with um a few a handful of
entrepreneurs um on a semi-regular basis
and just see how how's it going and the
question that i always ask is what's
your attention where's your attention
and if someone comes in and they seem
really really like scattered i already
know that their attention's all over the
place they're super spread they're less
able so of course they can't grow their
business because they don't have the
very horsepower the main resource that
allows them to grow and push
right and so look at your life look at
your relationship with your spouse loved
one look at your habits
how you wake up how you eat how you
exercise do you drink here's an example
for why we stop drinking all right and
it has nothing to do with any kind like
there's no religious anything
regarding this we stopped drinking
because i realized that i would drink
at night on a fairly regular basis not
like i always had some issue with it i
really didn't i mean i drank a lot but i
just whatever the point is this is that
i would i would drink in the evenings
because i would it would it would help
me just de-stress but help me unwind
but what that does is it masks the thing
that is taking my attention that i have
anxiety on
right and so if you need to take a drink
to unwind then it means you have things
that you have not resolved and so one by
one what happened is that when i stopped
drinking everything got really loud
and so i had to face and confront the
things that i had not resolved yet and
so in the beginning it's the hardest but
then what happens is once you've
actually resolved all of those things
the desire to drink goes away because
you're like well i actually feel really
good right now i don't want to mess that
up
and so it flips but it took it took
probably six months for that to happen
from it
um and so i'm just giving that as an
example of um
of what of what having your attention
split and kind of getting gaining that
attention back can be so look at your
life look at your relationships look at
your habits and the things that are
taking your attention you need to handle
complete the cycles and get the
attention back so you can work on the
one thing that you're trying to grow and
if you have side hustles and side
businesses
get rid of them
kill them that's what people like people
come and they pay tons of money to tell
them
do one thing and the only reason that
they listen is because we make one
and i'm telling you right now that's
what i would tell you do one thing focus
do one thing focus
saying it again that's why most times uh
when someone comes in they're like hey i
want to start an online business in a
food prep business and
and and uh whatever right all at the
same time because one of them is going
to take off it doesn't work that way all
of them could take off you could have a
billion dollar
uh food prep business you could have a
billion dollar gym business like your
business like having more businesses is
a farce i was talking to a gym owner the
other day and he's like yeah i mean two
paychecks is better than one and i was
like no one fat paycheck is better than
two you can have a hundred million
dollar roofing business right that just
repairs rooms you don't need to do
general contracting and also windows and
also gutters and roofs you can just do
one thing and be really really really
really really good at it and make as
much money as you want and so just break
that belief of yourself of like i have
to have three things in order to make
more money you know you don't you don't
it's not true you need one thing i had
someone who's in the real estate space
who was doing real estate coaching
after uh her first month of being in the
coaching uh called me up and was like
there's just not enough real estate
agents she was doing like 200 000 a
month and i was like real estate agents
i said how how how small of a market do
you think micro gym owner is
i was like you literally outnumber my
market a hundred to one and i was like
and we are out doing outpacing your
revenue
twenty to one
it's it's just these beliefs that we
have that are silly and i can tell you
that the the higher up you go all of
those limiting beliefs disappear and you
just see people who operate a very high
level very quiet very clean they they're
like if someone walks in the door and
there's any negativity those people just
get up and late nothing personal i just
can't have that in my life right someone
complained someone's negative oh this
weather ah traffic stop like no worries
i'm just gonna get up and go it's
nothing personal right that's how they
handle themselves so um thank you guys
for your attention um i hope i gave you
a positive return on it that was my
intention um this wasn't a normal uh
type of uh
video that i would normally make but it
was something that was like on my mind
and i just had uh two or three calls
recently where i had told people to
consolidate their businesses get rid of
one two or three businesses and then
within a matter of 30 days
two of those people
had a multiple of 3x on their total
revenue between of what they were doing
before within a 30-day period just by
getting their attention back look at
what you can consolidate lots of
everyone i appreciate you and um
shoot a like for someone who feels
really distracted or if you have a
spouse and you're like we should clean
up our stuff
tag them so that you can clean it up and
uh
have to get some attention back all
right that's a lot have an amazing
thursday and i will talk to you guys
soon all right